il est une source d'inspiration pour
justin trudeau mahatma gandhi qui a vécu
dans cet ashram une visite culturelle
suivie d'une autre cette fois dont l'un
des plus grands temples hindous du pays
il se rendra plus tard cette semaine au
temple d'or des sikhs à une mosquée et
une église
le programme de son voyage a été pensé
pour ménager les susceptibilités
surtout dans le contexte où des médias
ont insinué qu'on retrouve au canada d
appui aux mouvements qui aspire à la
création d'un pays
dans le pendjab indien dès l'arrivée de
justin trudeau
sept analystes affirmaient que l'inde
s'attend à ce que le premier ministre
canadien se prononce sur les cinq
radicaux au canada sont irritants parce
que pour l'inde de séparatisme
comme pour n'importe quel pays incluant
canada est un sujet qui est très
sensible
sensible et tenace le ministre de la
défense du canada à jeddah jian a lui
même été accusé d'être sympathisants de
ce mouvement par le ministre en chef du
pendjab
une information que le ministre sajjad a
nié catégoriquement
pour apaiser les tensions justin trudeau
a accepté de rencontrer ce ministre en
chef et entre temps il répète que le
canada appuie une inde unis ça fait
partie des valeurs canadiennes
d'accepter une diversité de points de
vue et de de perspectives mais en fait
au jour soit dans le respect on rejette
la violence et
l'un toute approche basée sur la haine
l'itie qu'on aime représente une petite
minorité mais au canada ils forment la
communauté la plus importante parmi les
indo canadiens comme d'autres premiers
ministres avant lui justin trudeau essai
de manoeuvrer pour ni se mettre à dos ce
bloc d'électeurs ni offensé l'inde avec
qui ils tentent justement d'accroître
ses relations d'affaires
ici madeleine la mort et radio-canada
mumbai